Hey, what's up guys hang out today with Dennis roady?
I have a channel called how to prank it up
Where you go, and I teach you how to track you friends and family so he just flew in today
And we've been thinking some ideas of how we can relate projects to pranks and we literally just count this idea
What if we took a mousetrap and turn it into some kind of pressure activated switch like the perfect prank dude
We run the story now grab some mousetraps and see what kind of we can  come up
Let's go get to it
alright guys, so we just found the gardening section
This is where you get rid of rodents
Little Tomcat brands kind of cool cause they got like the little cheddar cheddar cheese, and then a cheese's pins already there for you. oh!!
alright
So we are back in the works, and we've got some power tools. I am gonna drill a couple of pilot holes
That's just so the wood doesn't crack when we screw into it , so we're gonna use a pair of needle nose pliers
We're gonna bend this thing so that the loop kind of matches up with that  hold this back anymore, right? No there we go
Alright, so that's what we have together. Hopefully that's gonna work. We just need something for the screws to hold into place
So now you probably could just get away with putting one or two screws on here
So in a snap shut you got one electrical connection we put two on the corners and connect the band
Just in case because if one end is like hooked up
And not making contact the other side still is so that's just kind of give this a little bit of redundancy
This piece of the spring does not move it's static through the entire process, but it is fully connected to this band here there
We go okay cool, so we got our contact back here that rigs up this entire system when that's pulled back
It's completely separated then we have this down here. That'll be our secondary system
And there'll be a gap in between we don't need this
And we don't need this we just have one contact point there one contact point there when that's now shut
Circuits complete and then we're on to something
Shop classroom all right guys we rigged up a little demonstration here. We got this hooked up to 120 volts Ac which
I don't recommend that's house power, but I made this little contraption. I'll turn on appliances
We just want to see if it'll work so to set the switch all we have to do is keep the mousetrap open
Put something that's really heavy over it
And then walk away if you want you can conceal the wires and then this really comes along
I say hey could you give me a hole saw?
So you know that got aladdin where a booth lifts up that red Julie's not supposed to touch and it sets off all the booby
Traps that's kind of what this is. Oh, so there's a pressure switch there, so when it lifted
Yeah, we got a run made out of a mouse trap
So you know I can set this back, and you won't be able to make it work. Yeah, it doesn't work now
We got to find something heavier um
That was real that was not a prank nobody does that
I know an even simpler version of this mouse trap is just to connect the wires directly to the pins themselves
I just took the staple out and reposition it on the corner and tied the wire to it and you can see
It when it snaps it makes the electrical circuit complete you don't even need any extra hardware
just a couple of wires and a mousetrap
it's policy to use this off of like a car battery or six volt lantern battery
So this is kind of an out of the box idea. I went to the auto parts store
I pick up a car horn and apparently this is one of the loudest ones
So we're going to [rig] this thing to a car battery and then imagine you've got some kind of a heavy [object] on here
Somebody lifts it up, or kicks it off or whatever and then this
They have no idea what's hanging on or how to turn it off [do] is a living where would you hook it up?
Have you had a car worn it you could put anywhere?
Anywhere, where would you put it apparently we're going to ring this up in the living room
So let's go get the car battery and see if we can make this thing work
ah
So we gotten a really good location
It's really cool with [it], but the kids are coming home from school and then going to soccer practice
So we're totally gonna prank them. We got a box of candy
My kids are gonna. Love same concept except this one's kind of cool to just watch and the kids pick this up
That one's gonna go off at the same time this bottom was gonna open up all this
Different snacks on the spills in the  double braid family that pranks together stacy
There we go. I smell poop waste did you poop your pants?
Check this out actually dented the wall battle scars of a prank gone wrong
So you can see this works really well with something like the car horn and a battery prank
We totally got my wife did
What would you guys put it put it underneath the garage door so when the door opens it goes off under the laundry basket?
what if you even made a package where the prank was inside the box?
Turn this thing upside down and have it underneath the box. No it goes off the hole. I've taken root
So there you have it guys that's how to make a quick and easy pressure release mechanism using a mousetrap. this thing's awesome
I would suggest using this off of 6 volt 9 volt or 12 volt batteries car batteries will work. Just as well
and
You can have a lot of fun rigging up booby traps and prank anyway big thanks to Dennis roady for flying out here to do
This project with us today was a ton of fun, and we're gonna be doing something on his channel with mousetrap
Yeah - the electricity just the mousetrap
Strengths true friends of them should be a little bit safer things you can try at home will see over there or in the next
Video, that's you then
Muster Watch Macgyver a lot
you